dès les premières minutes le ton est
donné au stade léo lagrange ce derby de
nationale 2 entre poissy versailles sera
engagée sous les yeux des trois cents
spectateurs malgré une belle frappe en
début de match des joueurs pisciacais ce
sont les visiteurs qui dominent cette
première période sans réussite 0 0 à la
pause
mais souvent la possession du ballon a
été c'est assez cohérent dans ce qu'on
faisait en tout ce transfert du milieu
de terrain mais à la proche du but on
n'a pas spécialement été très dangereux
note reproche c'est d'avoir pas plus
d'avoir réussi à convertir pense que on
est tellement stressé ne pas prendre de
poids pour rester et crispé dans l'autre
camp et qu'on balance tout au retour des
vestiaires poissy se reprend les bleu et
jaune sont proches de marquer à
plusieurs reprises mais les joueurs
manquent de réalisme et aurait pu se
faire surprendre en fin de match comme
sur ce dernier coup franc à l'entrée de
la surface de réparation
le tir passe au-dessus de la
transversale score final 0 à 0 on a plus
d'occasions franches
et c'est quelques coups d'éclat tison
mais nous céder au casot france donc je
pense que nous on doit l'emporter
d'un côté on est déçus parce qu'on aura
beaucoup d'occasions france et d'un
autre côté satisfait parce qu'on prend
le premier point on a souffert et puis
après on sait les situations que nous
avons eues sur la situation des attaques
rapides
on a vu comme une deux trois approches
avoir réellement une occasion très
franche mais on aurait pu éventuellement
convertir sur une hésitation mieux
négocier après cette rencontre poissy
pointe à la dernière place du classement
de nationale 2 verset de son côté 7e du
championnat